Just left Iran a couple days ago.
A very interesting trip.
Usually my content is about
uplifting human stories
and I will make a great video on Iran.
[inhales deeply]
But I'm compelled to tell the story of
what's going on right now on the ground
with sanctions.
And so...
I have an interesting perspective
on the country because I'm an American guy
but I traveled there as an Italian,
I have two passports.
And so Americans have to go
on a government minded tour
with an official
and they can't go off on their own.
I have the privilege
because of my Italian passport
to be able to travel wherever.
So here's what I saw.
I was there three years ago
and the feeling,
especially in Tehran is very different.
So these sanctions
are really pinching the place
and you hear John Bolton talk about...
[John Bolton] Do everything we can
to squeeze Iran hard.
As the British say, to squeeze them
until the pips squeak.
And we're gonna do everything we can...
PETER: They want to bring
oil revenue to zero.
Oil revenue makes up
80% of the tax base in Iran.
[John Bolton] The Rial, the currency
has declined by 70% since the sanctions.
Inflation has quadrupled.
The country is in recession,
you're seeing...
PETER: And all these
so-called accomplishments
of how you're crippling a country
and that all sounds great geopolitically.
Like I'm gonna lose...
I'm gonna lose my pawn to gain a knight.
But the reality is
on the ground in Iran
especially in Tehran,
people are feeling it.
They're feeling it with their jobs
with being able to support their children.
So you have middle class,
now a lot of them going down.
Many ending up on the streets.
You have a sadness.
There's overall, like,
there's a sadness in people
and that energy sort of
takes an inertia and compiles.
So you feel like this malaise in Tehran.
I don't want to paint it as all terrible.
There's people smiling
and living their lives
and not everyone's suffering
but a lot of people...
Their lives are going downhill.
Every young person wants out.
[people chattering]
Like how much has
the price of chicken gone up let's say?
50%
Depression medication,
I was told by a pharmacist
50% of the population
is on depression meds.
Food costs have, at the low end
I've heard, doubled
in the last five months.
At the high end, I've heard quadrupled.
So these successes with sanctions...
You're crippling a country, great.
But who suffers?
Not the politicians,
and they never do, right?
It's the politicians with coffers of money
but who suffers out of this?
Iranians.
The irony is this is probably the most
pro-American country on the planet.
As far as like pro-American people.
When I say I'm Italian
people are cool, they're like,
"Wow cool, Italy, great.
When I say American it's like
[woosh]
Way up here.
It's crazy.
And they're getting
pinched hard by their government.
They're getting pinched hard
by the US government
and
[scoffs] it breaks my heart
because this is...
This is one of the most hospitable,
open cultures on planet earth
and they're taking it from all ends.
And so I just want to
bring awareness to this.
I just want to shout this out
because people cannot
understand this unless...
Well they can understand it the most
when they live through it.
The second stage would be me
being able to witness it
and see it for myself
and then when you just hear on the news...
Here are some sanctions
being implemented by these...
These people that have
very little humanity in them.
[John Bolton] Iran, that's one of
the reasons why the Iranian economy
is tanking right now
and we're gonna ramp this up.
This is gonna be a big squeeze.
That's what President Trump means
when he says, "Maximum pressure."
WOMAN: Nowadays people in my country
aren't happy as usual
because of the bad situation
that we (have).
Like what are the conversations at home?
Do you guys try to avoid all this stuff
or you talk about it all the time?
Talk about it all the time.
But when you hear a guy talk about it
and it might sound good when
you're that far detached from humanity
but the reality on the ground...
I think he even has enough of a heart
or could overcome his ego enough
if he sat on a bench in Tehran
and noticed
the differences after sanctions.
Might not feel so proud.
I didn't think we would end up like this.
Because of the state of Iran right now...
Exactly because
it's really difficult to live.
I hope this brings awareness
to Americans or foreigners
that Iranians are
feeling the hurt right now
and Iranians, I want you to know that...
You don't need
to hear it from me, obviously.
Persian culture has been through a lot.
It's been through challenges
for thousands of years and...
[inhales deeply]
You will overcome
whatever comes at you right now
and know that all Americans
or Westerners, if they knew your situation
would be with you 100% because
nobody likes to see others unjustly get
manipulated and maneuvered like this.
Sanctions, John Bolton, Donald Trump,
you can sound tough, you can sound cool...
It's not cool.
It's nothing to be proud of.
It's not anything to stand on
when you ruin people's lives.
[claps]
That's it.
PETER: That was video, I tricked you.
[all laughing]
Do you hate Americans?
[all] No!
PETER: Are you sure? Are you sure?
-Yes.
-Really?
WOMAN: It goes behind
hating American people
and we love all the people
around the world.
MAN: Thank you, Peter.
[applause fades into John Bolton speaking]
[Bolton] The President's policy here
is maximum pressure
and I think what he means
by maximum pressure is maximum pressure.
The aim is to drive
Iranian oil exports to zero.
[Bolton fades into Peter speaking]
I'm sorry, it's just um...
We are sorry too.
We are sorry for our situation.
[Bolton] Let's be clear, we're gonna
have sanctions that even go beyond this.
We're not simply gonna be content
with the level of sanctions that
existed under Obama in 2015.
More are coming
and even more important perhaps
we are actually going to have
very strict, very tight enforcement
of the sanctions that do exist.
Iran right now is in
the escape and evasion mode.
They're gonna try
and get around the sanctions.
We're determined to prevent that.
♪ guitar and harmonica ♪
[skateboard clacking]
[audio slowly fades]